[Musique]
c'est le rêve de milliers d'enfants
devenir astronaute déplacera à la
première fois que l' agence spatiale
européenne a recruté c'était à sa
création en 1975
plus de 2000 candidats aux divers se
profile et cinq français dans la
dernière ligne droite
tous les cinq ont franchi avec succès
les redoutables épreuves physiques et
intellectuelles de sélection cinq ans et
dont charles ses jambes seront peut-être
celle du premier astronaute français
il a 35 ans et a été sélectionné avec 44
autres candidats son prénom
charles et parmi les épreuves charles a
dû résister à la terrible centrifugeuses
labellisé 3g autre épreuve celle du
tapis roulant incliné et forcément à la
fin on est un petit peu essoufflée
d'autres tests comme ce test musculaire
est très éprouvant charles ne fera
malheureusement pas partie du voyage
devenir un chevalier du ciel n'est
franchement pas donné à tout le monde la
sélection prend parfois des allures de
koh lanta sur le plan physique
les astronautes doivent effectuer en
début de stage toute une série de tests
et d'épreuves qui sont globalement d
entraînement à la survie dans des
conditions particulièrement hostile et
cela en cas d'atterrissage accidentelle
de la navette pour postuler une
excellente condition physique est donc
primordial en d'autres termes pour
simplifier avoir les toffes d'un héros
avoir l'étoffé d'un héros et la tête
bien pleine l'astronaute jean françois
clervoy lui rappeler lors de la
précédente campagne de recrutement en
on demande à ces jeunes d'avoir un
minimum d'expérience professionnelle
dans un domaine opérationnel de type
pilote technique de type ingénieur ou
scientifique de type médecin ou
astrophysiciens officielle des
particules et puis d'être très motivée
et le dernier français très motivés
c'était lui il est pilote de ligne il a
un cv à faire pas lié à la plupart
d'entre nous il a 31 ans et il va
devenir le nouvel astronaute français
thomas pesquet alors si cette expérience
hors du commun vous intéresse et que
vous vous sentez les toffes du futur
pesqué il ne vous reste qu'à postuler
[Musique]